est ce le grand retour des gilet jaune
samedi
des collectifs appel à manifester
partout en france un air de déjà vu
retour sur cinq moments clés de cette
colère sociale et gilet jaune c'est
d'abord un mouvement né sur la toile le
24 octobre 2018
ghislain coûta un mécanicien narbonnais
poste une vidéo sur facebook
la raison de sa colère la flambée des
prix du carburant
la vidéo devient virale plus de 5
millions de vues en une semaine on a
tous un gilet jaune bagnols foutez là en
évidence sur le tableau de bord toute la
semaine la fin jusqu'au 17
un petit code couleur pour montrer vous
êtes d'accord avec nous avec le
mouvement
trois semaines plus tard ce 17 novembre
des centaines de milliers de personnes
en chasubles jaunes occupent les ronds
points les péages et descendre dans les
rues
on est nombreux en est nombreux et je
pense c'est que si le gouvernement ne
recule pas on sera encore plus nombreux
parce que là ça ça motive quand même ça
motive on voit que les gens sont
concernés
le mouvement est lancé le 1er décembre
acte iii du mouvement paris le théâtre
de scènes de guérilla urbaine
l'arc de triomphe est pris pour cible
les magasins sont incendiés c'est des
images qui sont choquantes et qui sont
fortes et je sais pas si on va se faire
entendre d'une manière ou d'une autre
las il n'a pas entendu qui avait de la
colère quelque part en réaction le 10
décembre
emmanuel macron annonce plusieurs
mesures sociales parmi elles
l'annulation de la hausse de la csg pour
certains retraités ou encore la
revalorisation du smic le salaire d'un
travailleur au smic augmentera de 100
euros par mois dès 2019 sans qu'il en
coûte 1 euro de plus pour l'employeur
insuffisant estimé gilet jaune
le mouvement continue à nice le 23 mars
geneviève le gué une militante d'attac
et grièvement blessé lors d'une
manifestation non autorisée piétiner
leurs charges policières
des éléments ont établi que
contrairement à ce qui pouvait être
interprété des premières images il y a
eu un contact direct entre un membre des
forces de l'ordre de l'ordre et madame
le guet le mouvement s'étiole au
printemps 2010 9 et le kobe 19 est
passée par là
ses conséquences sociales avec les
colères se réveille samedi sera l'acte
96 des gilet jaune
[Musique]